[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild pass auf Dich auf komm nicht zu
spät nach Hause geh nicht allein achte
im Dunkeln auf
dich alles abgedroschen Klischees und
Ratschläge die man und besonders Frau
schon so oft gehört hat und bei einem
einzigen Mal von hunderttausenden geht
es schief kommt der dunkle Mann schafft
es jemand nicht nach Hause von so einem
Fall erzählen wir heute ich bin Stefan
Netzeband und ich bin Mirko Kasim mir
hallo zusammen bei unserem heutigen Fall
unterstützt uns wieder bildchefreporter
Frank Schneider er kann sich besonders
an ein brutales Detail erinnern ja
dieser sogenannte killkopfgriff den muss
man schon kennen den muss man geübt
haben mus muss man trainiert haben weil
man dann auf eine Person zugeht und
sofort mit den Händen und mit den
Fingern so gezielt am Hals zugreift dass
das Opfer gar keine Chance mehr oder
wenig auf Gegenwehr hat ja auch sofort
mehr oder wenig die Luft abdrückt wir
sprechen heute von Bianca Burbach 32
Jahre alt Sozialarbeiterin die auch noch
studierte und alleinerziehende Mutter
einer damals 11jährigen Tochter am Abend
des 25 April 2007 wurde sie ermord und
bis heute konnte kein Täter Ding fest
gemacht werden Frank Schneider hatte
damals mit diesem Fall zu tun und jetzt
beschäftigt er sich wieder damit
ungewöhnlich an dem Fall ist es es auch
ein Cold Case ist auch von der Polizei
jetzt noch mal neu aufgenommen worden in
nordestfahen werden viele kohkäes neu
aufgenommen man hatte eine dnspur vom
Täter und kam trotzdem nicht weiter man
hat an die 4000 Menschen überprüft also
Männer die möglicherweise ins Profil
passen und ist trotzdem nicht
weitergekommen und das ist schon schon
sehr ungewöhnlich es könnte also sein
dass die Frau ein wirklich reines
Zufallsopfer war dass dieser Täter an
dem Abend auf der Jagd war nach einer
Frau nach einem Opfer und diese Bianca
burwach damals einfach nur ein
Zufallsopfer war und was den Fall
natürlich auch noch so besonders macht
er ist so tragisch weil sie
alleinerziehend war hatte eine
schulpflichtige Tochter und die musste
dann ohne Eltern aufwachsen also mal von
vorn Bianca Burbach besucht an diesem
Abend im April 2007 einen Elternabend im
Lütz das ist ein Kulturzentrum in der
siegender Innenstadt in den schönen
großen Rollen eines ehemaligen
Gymnasiums eines Lyzeums genauer gesagt
daher auch der Name in dem Komplex
unweit von Altstadt und Einkaufsstraße
sind Veranstaltungsräume aber auch ein
Restaurant ihre Wohnung wiederum liegt
an der Freudenberger Straße unweit des
malerischen
wellersberges eine schöne Wohngegend mit
reihhäuser Blocks aber auch
Einfamilienhäusern vom lüz hierhin sind
es je nach Schrittempo vielleicht 15 bis
20 Minuten zwischen Lütz und Wellersberg
hat Siegen seine schroffe Seite hier
liegen der Bahnhof Gleise Schnellstraßen
über und Unterführungen und Betonbrücken
keine schöne Route wirklich aber da muss
man wie an diesem Abend auch Bianca
buchstäblich durch und hier schlägt der
Mörder zu Schneider fastst zusammen ja
es ist ein ganz besonders dramatischer
tragischer und auch brutaler Mord eine
junge Frau alleinerziehende Mutter geht
von einem Elternabend nach Hause und es
ist gar nicht mal tief in der Nacht es
ist 23 Uhr und sie geht von der
Gaststätte wo der Elternabend ist nach
Hause und über eine Brücke am Bahnhof in
Siegen und dort lauert ihr der Mörder in
einem Gebüsch auf greift sie sofort
brutal an zieht sie in ein gebüch
vergewaltigt sie dort und tötet sie
schließlich auch indem er Gewalt gegen
ihren Hals aus ü so wie die Polizei das
beschrieben hat wie die Kollegen vom
Portal der Westen gut zusammenfassen ist
der Abend des 25 April 2007 ein warmer
Frühlingsabend die Biergärten sind schon
offen im Fernsehen läuft das
Halbfinalspiel der Champions League
zwischen Chelsea London und dem FC
Liverpool die Siegener Innenstadt ist
voller Menschen die sich mitten in
dieser Arbeitswoche allmählich auf den
Heimweg
machen das Areal der ort ist zwar
ungemütlich und dunkel aber doch
übersichtlich genug um die Tat zu
rekonstruieren was die Kripo natürlich
versucht ja die damals 32-Jährige Bianca
Bubach eine alleineziehende Mutter war
2007 war der Fall am 25 April gegen 23
Uhr auf dem Heimweg von der Gaststätte
lüs in Siegen und zwar war dort der
Elternabend ihrer Tochter und sie ist
dann am Bahnhof über eine relativ ja
einsame Fußgängerbrücke gegangen an der
Tiergartenstraße und dort D auf einem
trampelfahrt kurz vor der Brücke muss
ihr der Mörder in einem Gebüsch
aufgelauert haben Sie also völlig
überrumpelt haben hat sie dann sofort
ins Gebüsch gezogen hat sie vergewaltigt
und dann getötet und das Ungewöhnliche
an dem Fall ist dass man eine DNA des
Täters sicherstellen konnte aber der
Täter bis heute trotz Tausender Proben
von DNA von möglicherweise
Tatverdächtigen Männern zu keinem
Ergebnis geführt hat und er einer dieser
Cold Case Fälle ist die normalerweise
gerade wenn es so Sexualstraftaten sind
und Derna gefunden wird häufig doch
geklärt werden und hier läuft jemand
frei herum der möglicherweise sich auch
noch mal ein neues Opfer suchen könnte
die Mordkommission stellt also
einerseits eine Sexualstraftat fest
zusätzlich hat der Täter Bianca Burbach
aber auch das Portemonnaie abgenommen
später warf er die Geldbörse von der
sogenannten hufeisenbrücke am Siegener
Bahnhof sie wurde einige Tage später
gefunden auf einer Lokomotive die in der
Tatnacht unter der Brücke gestanden
hatte
dnapuren eine Geldbörse und theoretisch
viele viele Zeugen die an diesem lauen
Frühlingsabend auch unterwegs waren
eigentlich keine schlechten
Voraussetzungen für die Ermittler aber
es ist kein Treffer dabei unter den
Spuren und Hinweisen und so rätseln die
Ermittler und mit ihnen Journalist Frank
Schneider also es gibt zwei Theorien bei
dieser Tat einmal dass es ein
Zufallsopfer war dass die Frau einfach
zur falschen Zeit am falschen war dass
Bianca Bubach auf ihrem Heimweg auf den
Mann getroffen ist der ein Opfer gesucht
hat und sie war eben die Frau die in dem
Moment dort vorbeikam als er sich
unbeobachtet fühlte und sie da
vergewaltigt und getötet hat eine zweite
Möglichkeit ist dass es gezielt auf
Bianca bobach abgesehen hatte weil sie
diesen Weg nicht nur vom Elternabend
nach Hause ging sondern auch wenn sie
norchmal auf dem Heimweg von der Arbeit
war und deswegen könnte es auch sein
dass sie ihr gezielt aufgelauert hat
dagegen spricht natürlich dass er nicht
gefunden wurde obwohl es eine DNA gibt
denn man hat das ganze Lebensumfeld
Nachbarschaft Bekanntschaften
Arbeitsplatz alles überprüft alle Männer
über 16 und hat trotzdem keinen Treffer
gefunden und das spricht doch
möglicherweise eher dafür dass es ein
Zufallsopfer war was dann eben die Jagd
auf den Mörder auch so schwierig macht
für die Mordkommission und das ist das
vertragte dass die vielgepriesene
Analyse des Erbgutes nichts bringt weil
es zu keiner erfassten Person passt ich
will bestimmt nicht vom perfekten Mord
sprechen aber es macht mich Mirko an
unserer podcastreihe schon manchmal
nachdenklich wie viele Fälle zu cold
cases werden insofern haben wir Frank
Schneider hier auch gezielt gefragt ob
die dnaanalyse von ja vor etwa 15 Jahren
dann noch up to date ist heute ja in dem
Fall ist es schon so dass die DNA die
gesichert wurde ausreichend ist und die
DNA die von den Männern genommen wird
natürlich auch also ist hier nicht so
dass man wie in manchen anderen Fällen
manchen anderen ccase Fällen einfach die
DNA neu auswertet oder möglicherweise
neue Spuren entdeckt das ist hier nicht
so man hat eine gute DNA aber man findet
eben nicht das gegenüber den Treffer den
Täter und das ist an dem Fall so
schwierig für die
Mordkommission deswegen ist man am Ende
auch noch mit sogenanntem Täterwissen an
die Öffentlichkeit gegangen und hat
gefragt wer kennt jemand der einen
sogenannten gezielten kehlkopfgriff
einsetzen kann das heißt der das Opfer
sofort am Hals packt sie sofort so mehr
oder weniger mit mit den Fingern am
Kehlkopf zudrückt sie gar keine Chance
mehr hat auf eine Gegenwehr also der TÄ
extrem brutal vorgegangen eigentlich wie
ein Kampfsportler und darauf hofft man
jetzt dass möglicherweise da Menschen
sich finden die Wissen der kann das der
war zu der Zeit in Siegen der hat
vielleicht dort Bezüge hin der hat dort
gelebt oder wer war dort auf der
Durchreise aber auch selbst diese
Veröffentlichung dieser konkreten
Details haben leider überhaupt nicht zu
neuen Spuren geführt war der Täter also
Judoka ein käfigkämpfer oder gar ein
Elitesoldat aus dem räumlichen um eld
kam er offenbar nicht denn alle Männer
die im engeren Umkreis lebten aber auch
Männer die schon durch gewaltatten
aufgefallen waren wurden bei den
Ermittlungen und durch dnatests
überprüft und nach einer Sendung der
Reihe Aktenzeichen XY im August gab es
noch mal 30 Hinweise aber keine heiße
Spur verständlich also dass die Polizei
bis heute den kehlkopfgriff als perte
verfolgt den muss man trainiert haben
weil man dann auf eine Person zugeht und
sofort mit den Händen und mit den
Fingern so gezielt am Hals zugreift dass
das Opfer gar keine Chance mehr oder
weniger auf gegenwer hat ja auch sofort
mehr oder wenig die Luft abdrückt das
Opfer möglicherweise je nachdem wie
brutal dieser Griff ausgeführt wird auch
sofort oder sehr schnell bewusstlos wird
und das spricht dafür dass er irgendwie
eine Art Kampfsporttraining oder etwas
ausgeübt hat oder möglicherweise auch
bei Militär war oder ähnliches und
deshalb hat die Polizei gehofft dass es
Menschen gibt die vielleicht sagen ja
ich kenne der kann das einer der diesen
Griff kann der war mit mir beim
Kampfsport oder der hat sich damit zicht
sogar gebrüstet dass er das kann
deswegen hatte man die Hoffnung mit der
Veröffentlichung dieses Details dass der
Täter so vorgegangen ist mit diesem
killkopfgriff dass man da auf den Täter
kommen würde aber leider hat das auch
keine neue heiße Spur gebracht Frank
Schneider hofft sehr dass die neuen
ermittlungsbemühungen in diesem cold
casiss etwas bringen denn den erfahrenen
Reporter hat der Mord bis heute nicht
losgelassen besonders berührt an Fall
hat mich dass dieses Opfer ein
schuldichtiges Mädchen hterlässt eine
Tochter die bis heute mit der Tat nicht
wirklich klar kommt was ja auch
nachvollziehbar ist sie ist nur mit
ihrer Mutter aufgewachsen und die Mutter
war dann plötzlich tot ermordet aus dem
Leben gerissen sie ging abends auf den
Eltern Abend also auch noch für ihre
Tochter sozusagen war sie unterwegs und
dann kommt dieser Mörder und und greift
sie so brutal an vergewaltigt und tötet
sie das war dramatisch und auch
schrecklich auch immer zu hören von der
Polizei dass gerade diese Tat zu klären
den so wichtig ist weil sie wollen eben
auch dass die Tochter endlich weiß was
ist mit Mama passiert warum ist das
passiert und wer ist der Täter und wir
haben den Täter er wird seiner gerechten
Strafe zugeführt und deswegen hat die
Mordkommission in Hagen auch wirklich
alles daran gesetzt diesen Fall noch zu
klären und tut es immer noch also diese
Fall ist ja nicht abgeschlossen mord
verjährt nie das ist aber hier nicht
einfach nur eine flosel sondern das ist
so man nimmt immer wieder noch neue
Spuren auf man war im Fernsehen mit dem
Fall man versucht immer wieder neue
Spuren zu finden um es endlich zu lären
um endlich auch der Tochter sagen zu
können das ist der Mann der deine Mutter
getötet
hat die Tochter ist heute Mitte 20 und
was sie genau macht das weiß man nicht
und das ist auch gut so finde ich nur
weil ihre Mutter einem Verbrechen zum
Opfer fiel ist sie selbst ja keine
Person des öffentlichen Interesses aber
es liegt auf der Hand dass sie die
allererste ist die diesen Fall gesüht
wissen will also die Tochter hat immer
noch Kontakt auch zur Mordkommission mit
den Medien sprechen möchte sie nicht sie
ist immer noch zu sehr belastet von
dieser schrecklichen Tat und sie führt
ein halbwegigst normales lebenens war
aber es ist immer noch für sie sehr
schwierig mit diesem schrecklichen und
brutalen Tod der Mutter
umzugehen pass auf Dich auf geh nicht zu
spät nach Hause geh nicht allein achte
im Dunkeln auf dich man würde es Bianca
burboch gerne durch eine Zeitmaschine
zurufen aber ganz ehrlich wir alle
begeben uns manchmal in Gefahren von
denen wir ja gar nichts wissen wir
könnten sonst ja auch gar nicht frei
Leben das ich ganz genauso Stefan zumal
Bianca in diesem konkreten Fall den Weg
über die hufeisenbrücke von der
Innenstadt nach Hause ja schon hunderte
Male gegangen ist und ohne ein gewisses
vertraauen in die Sicherheit unserer
Umgebung könnten wir eigentlich kein
erfülltes Leben führen auch wenn das
vielleicht manchmal trügerisch ist umso
wichtiger wäre es wenn Biancas Mörder
bestraft und aus dem Verkehr gezogen
würde
das war unser Fall für heute das skriipt
habe ich zusammen mit Frank Schneider
verfasst Postproduktion durch schwarz
audio berlin ich bin Stefan Netzeband
und hoffe ihr seid beim nächsten Fall
wieder dabei und das letzte Wort hat
heute Frank er bittet um eure Mithilfe
und damit sage ich schon mal bis zum
nächsten mal euer Mirko und euer Stefan
die Polizei hat ganz konkrete Fragen an
potenielle Zeugen die vielleicht doch
noch helfen können diesen schrecklichen
Mordfall aufzuklären zum einen möchten
Sie gerne wissen der Täter das Opfer
gezielt mit einem kehlkopfgriff
angegriffen wer hat jemand mal
beobachtet der so einen kehlkopfgriff
einsetzt wer kennt einen Kampfsportler
der das kann oder kennt jemanden der
damit sich gebrüstet hat dass er das
kann oder vielleicht gibt es sogar eine
Frau die entkommen konnte und von jemand
angegriffen wurde der ihr ebenso an den
Hals gefasst hat das nächste ist wer hat
an dem Tatabend also diesem 25 April
2007 Verdächtige Beobachtung gemacht wer
hat etwas gesehen eine Person gesehen
die sich komisch verhalten hat die
irgendwo hergelaufen ist wo sie nicht
hingehört sich immer wieder umgeguckt
hat wichtig ist noch mal für die
Erinnerung der Menschen an diesem Abend
fand das Halbfinalspiel der Champions
League zwischen Chelsea London und dem
FC Liverpool statt und damals war auch
die Siegner Innenstadt also in
Tatortnähe sehr voll es waren viele
Menschen unterwegs und noch eine Frage
der Polizei ist wer hat nach diesem 25
April 2007 jemand in seinem Umfeld
gehabt der sich plötzlich ganz anders
verhalten hat der möglicherweise auch
sein persönliches Umfeld verlassen hat
wo anders hingezogen ist wo anders
hingegangen ist plötzlich verschlossener
war sich nicht mehr mit jemand treffen
wollte also sich auffällig und anders
verhalten hat das sind die
entscheidenden Fragen und ja die
statsanwaltschaft Siegen hat bis heute
eine Belohnung für 5000 € ausgesetzt
wenn man Hinweise gehen kann die dann
zum Täter
führen die hat diese Folge von tartord
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Herrmann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland